diagonal TV 7 mars 2009
Topalov Kamski parti numéro 4 avec
Aurélie
d'acalor
bonjour bienvenue sur diagonal TV
spécial topalof Kamski et bien nous
recevons pour commenter ce match
exceptionnel demi-finale de championnat
du monde nous recevons une nouvelle
invité sur diagonal TV qu'on va vous
présenter aujourd'hui c'est Aurélie
d'acalor bonjour bonjour Alors Aurélie
tu es donc une joueuse d'échec
évidemment évidemment alors tu tu
officies depuis de nombreuses années
dans le milieu chiicain al tu as été
plusieurs fois championne de France en
fait chez les jeunes c'est vrai et
notamment dans les championnats mixtes
hein alors tu as gagné les championnats
féminins puisqu'il y a des championnat
féminin parce qu'il y a pas encore assez
de filles donc on essaie les encourager
aussi pour qu' joue mais tu as gagné
aussi un championnat toute catégorie
donc chez les garçons on dit mais en
fait c'est mixte ouais en poussin donc
cétait en quelle année ça c'était en 89
89 donc ça c'est un très bon résultat il
il y a très peu de filles qui ont gagné
chez les garçons en fait qui ont gagné
en mixte he en fait y a fierté ou qui
sait qu'il aurait d'autres bien sûr
Marie SBA oui bien sûr
et puis certainement d'autres que je
connais moins parce que je suis pas sûr
qu'il y en ait beaucoup peut-être mathil
conjou peut-être ou pas loin peut-être
je sais pas si elle a gagné mais
peut-être pas loin je sais pas non plus
on va dire sû donc tu as gagné en
poussin chez les mixtes tu as gagné chez
les filles en quelle catégorie aussi euh
il me semble bien benjamine cadette et
pupie quelque chose comme ça ouis et il
y avait d'autres filles qui qui jouent
encore contre qui contre qui tu avais
gagné à cette époque là et qui qui sont
encore actives il y en a encore qui
jouent mais beaucoup malheureusement on
abandonné ouais les filles choisissent
de fonder une famille et pas de jouer
aux échecs toute la vie souvent donc
c'est pas incompatible ça l'IT pas mais
ça réduit vachement le la possibilité de
faire des tournois comme font les les
messieurs en tout cas d'accord donc il
en reste plus beaucoup d'accord donc
plusieurs fois champion de France donc
respect déjà he parce que même chez les
jeunes faut quand même le faire hein moi
je suis jamais arrivé et alors
euh tu joues aussi aujourd'hui donc pour
le club lut s échec en fait à Paris
exactement donc qui est dirigé par Yv
laamel Yv laamorel qui est un monsieur
qui est très actif dans les échecs
depuis des années des décennies on va
dire très
connu moi-même dans ma province éloignée
bordelaise quand j'étais petit et dans
les années 80 j'entendais parler d'ilva
Morel donc c'était quand même quelqu'un
qui fait des choses alors tu joues le
Top 12 féminin évidemment avec avec le
tccheque et tu joues aussi le Top 16
donc il a et le championnat mixte là
aussi pour pour la place féminine en
fait parce qu' une féminine fémin il y a
un échqu féminin obligatoire dans chaque
équipe et heureusement et alors alors
tout récemment tu as fait une super
performance puisque tu as battu la
multiple championne de France Almira
scripchenko et oui le monstre Almira ça
arrive alors tu tu avais déjà plusieurs
fois joué contre elle pas du tout
c'était la première fois alors
raconte-nous en fait comment ça mais
comment ça s'est passé c'était une
partie d'échec contre Almira mon jeu à
moi puisque je ne connais pas la théorie
et puis Ben et puis se trouve que j'ai
gagné parce que j'étais tenace et que et
que j'ai sans doute bien joué sur la et
qu'elle était peut-être pas très
informelle au contraire donc et ben
voilà comme ça s'est passé et puis j'ai
gagné alors on va voir ça tout à l'heure
parce qu'on va regarder un petit peu
cette partie aussi en marge de ce de ce
match topalof Kamski très important à
suivre donc grand maître international
Almira scchenko multiple champion de
France donc c'est pas évident quand même
de c'est la preuve aussi qu'on peut
avoir donc un niveau de de Fort amateur
puisque c'est ton niveau tu es un niveau
de Fort
amateur et voilà tu peux gagner contre
un maître international ou un grand
maître international ben oui c'est des
choses pas impossibles ça arrive en
créant correctement des fois on arrive à
faire de belles choses voilà alors
qu'est-ce que tu dirais pour les filles
qui veulent jouer aux échecs alors et
ben pour les filles qui veulent jouer
aux échecs il faut travailler c'est
comme toute chose sans travail on
progresse pas il faut essayer
d'affronter des joueurs notamment plus
fort que soi c'est comme ça qu'on
progresse aussi et puis il faut croire
en ses idées parce que elles sont pas
forcément mauvaises et qu'à l'instant on
trouve des fois de belles choses alors
et a celle qui dirait oui mais le jeu
d'échec c'est un jeu de garçon
les mat bon c'est pas pour les filles
dommage non je trouve pas on se bat pas
avec des points il y a pas de ballon
c'est le cerveau qui s'en occupe et donc
je je pense qu'on peut faire des matchs
de cerveau avec les hommes sans
complications extrême quoi voilà donc ça
ça c'est ça c'est envoyé ça c'est bien
donc alors on va voir ta partie alors
parce que c'est quand même une grosse
perf hein quand un amateur bat un grand
maître international surtout la Miras
chrischenko qui est pas le qui est pas
la dernière venue multiple champion de
France euh elle elle est monstrueuse il
y a pas de match normalement voilà il y
a pas de match on va rappeler ton niveau
tuas tu as combien 2000 et quelques donc
2040 2040 tu as fait plus déjà tu as eu
des classement supérieurs ou je crois je
crois que mon plus fort hlo était
environ 2160 hlo d'accord donc tu es
aussi entre 2002 à peu près 2000 et 2002
voilà en fonction des
années on va voir cette partie très
rapidement surtout le moment crucial de
de cette partie donc cétait au top 12
féminin tu joues donc avec les Noirs
donc on va peut-être même se mettre du
côté noir carrément sa pas jouer avec
les Noirs c'est bien là le drame alors
on va tu sais pas jouer mais tu arrives
à gagner quand même face al on va voir
cette partie donc c'est une scandinave
ce coup des5 ici ça s'appelle une
défense scandinave avec une variante un
peu un peu folcllorique un peu
folcllorique d' mais qui se joue mais
qui qui effectivement peut-être un bon
moyen de sortir l'adversaire de ses
préparations des sentiers battu voilà
exactement alors on va dérouler un petit
peu les coups on va voir alors c'est tu
as joué en voit dans cette partie un jeu
plutôt resserré
h alors on va voir c'est très
intéressant ce qui s'est passé dans
cette partie c'est un peu une bombe à
retardement ça n'a l'air de rien et
visuellement c'est assez moche mais mais
en tout cas ça tient la route voilà on
voit ici que la dame noire ici a l'air
de partir un petit peu hors jeu mais
elle a quand même un œil sur le centre
elle est pas tout à fait exclue du jeu
ici elle Mira à cloué ici le cavalier D7
on a l'impression que les colis noirs
sont quand même très très resserrés
ouais mais le développement se continue
tranquillement petit rock petit rock le
cavalier sort recentre oui
voilà
on voit que tu as fini ton voilà tu as
fini ton développement tu as placé tes
pièces donc toutes les pièces sont
sorties tu as fait le donc tu as suivi
les grands standards de l'ouverture
exactement voilà comme quoi on peut
battre un grand maître en suivant les
principes du jeu d'échec voilà donc ça
c'est mieux d'ailleurs he parce que Sin
il voit
mieux voilà donc là ici attention
puisque Almira joue le coup des5 donc le
fou3 attaque vous voyez bien regardez
ici le fou3 attaque la dame donc c'est
un coup vicieux puceque il attaque à la
fois au centre et il attaque la dame
donc le coup dame à 8 est intéressant
puisqueévidemment il contreattaque sur
le fou C6 si les blancs prenaient ici
évidemment le fou C6 sauterait donc il
faut que les Blancs échangent d'abord le
fou
B7 et ici Almira joue le coup c alors
peut-être qu'elle aurait pu aussi
prendre ici sur le est-ce qu'elle aurait
pu prendre ici sur le pion 6 non je
pense que je prends le cavalier qui qui
se trouve gratuit là voilà donc ça perd
une pièce donc elle peut pas elle a pas
le temps en fait de prendre ce pion ce
pionci donc elle attaque d'abord la tour
et la tour juste àend vient protéger la
case a 6 c'est important parce qu'on
veut prendre 6 de la tour et pas du pion
pour pas casser le la défense du roi
pass fablir davantage
ou pion prend tour prend F3 donc on voit
la suite alors ici voilà un coup
important ici
euh ah oui mince alors je crois qu'on fa
c'est pas grave voilà voyà ce qui se
passe ici voilà le fou attention ici le
fou attaque le cavalier et la tour ici 4
est attaqué le C leare coup dame 8
protège la tour et là le problème que
almiran n'a pas vu en fait sur ce coup-l
c'est que le cavalier C6 ici n'a plus de
case de sortie et voilà c'est en fait
c'est ça qu'elle a raté exactement
entrée gratuite sortie payante elle a
pas dû le voir trè gratuite sortie
payante c'est c'est pas mal regardez ce
cavalier toutes les cases ici sont
prises par les Noirs ici c'est protégé
par les tours ici par la tour et donc ce
cavalier n'a plus du tout de case de
sortie et malgré ce que joue Almira
c'est l'échange ici du cavalier F6 la
dame8 protège bien la tour 4 qu'elle s
dit que je voulais pas doubler elle a
pas calculé jusqu'au bout je sais pas et
donc là Mira c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est résigné parce que là dit B je p
je perds une une pièce une pièce donc
elle a elle a elle essaie quand même de
de d'affaiblir le roi noir et d'essayer
de s'en sortir quand même al attention
il y a un petit piège ici qu' a une
menace des Noirs c'est de faire fou
échec bien sûr puis la dame C6 il va
prendre après la dame la dame F6 donc il
faut faire attention à ça évidemment
elle fait attention et alors là une
proposition de de quasiment d'échec
perpétuel alors ça c'est un moment
crucial de la partie aussi mais oui on
peut dire parce qu'elle me propose nul
indirectement en répétant les coups
parceque nombre de TR vous savez que
c'est nul oui j'ai refusé au 3è de jouer
le même coup et voilà ici si tu reviens
là et qu'elle refait échec c'est nul
c'est nul voilà donc tu jou je dis allez
une pièce de plus tant pis c'est Almira
mais essayons alors tu as quand même
essayé donc là il il y a quand même
notion de culot là faut pas avoir peur
parce que peut-être un joueur qui pour
la première fois la possibilité
d'annuler face à un maître ou un grand
maître international va se dire ben je
prends le demi-point je pose la question
évidemment de toute façon et là tuas tu
as choisi de de la jouer donc c'est
quand même fight hein c'està c'est
Aurélie dcalor ça le C aux échecs en
tout cas d'accord alors dam prend ici
donc al ici très joli coup des Noirs
alors ça c'est un coup très intéressant
parce que la tour B7 était totalement
inactive le coup tour B5 la tour veut se
centraliser par exemple en E5 ou
peut-être en D5 aussi euh ou en C5
Bonfin en tout cas elle rentre en jeu
alors qu'en B7 elle jouait pas donc très
important B8 l'idée est là hein c'est de
la recycler par icià donc échec le jour
bouge ici les blancs essayent de de
mettre les tours au centre
voilà il y a des échanges ici ouais
voilà il y a des prises ici tac on va
voir la fin voilà échec au roi voilà le
roi doit aller sur la case H1 et là roi
F8 alors coup étrange mais en fait ro F8
c'est fait pour éviter le coup dame D8
qui était pénible qui est pénible parce
qu'il répète les échecs et puis il
m'embête un peu il me laisse pas la
marge de manœuvre que que je souhaite
donc je réduis un petit peu les
possibilités
pour si H7 pour essayer de créer
des des menaces sur le roi essayie de de
menacer des choses en fait c'est
difficile les blancs sont déjà
potentiellement perdus donc fout des c
très intéressants parce que un ça libère
le potentiel de la tour ici sur le roi
et puis de ça bouche la tour des1 qui
peut plus pénétrer dans le C adverse
petit échec et la roi j'ai vite il y a
plus d'échec voilà fini les blancs
peuvent plus et après dame C6 encore un
coup d'Almira dame 2 et c'est terminé
parce que les Blancs ne peuvent plus
parer le mat il y a pas d'échec il y a
juste un échec ici possible et après ro
G7 il y a plus d'échec en même pas il y
a la dame d'ailleurs la dame 2 qui
prendrait la dame ici d'ailleurs et si
on fait un échec là il suffit de bouger
le roi et c'est terminé on peut plus
parer l'échec en imat en H2 donc une
très belle victoire al petite erreur d'
mirirac a laissé donc ce fameux cavalier
en prise et oui euh un oubl peut-être
voilà un oubli mais qu'il fallait quand
même voilà ici ben il fallait voir que
ce cavalier peut pas sortir et donc
c'est c'est une position resserrée où
les Noirs finalement en quelque sorte
ont tendu un piège au blanc un peu
qu'ils ont pas vu donc une belle
victoire c'est pas mal ça oui c'est bien
tu es contente de ça alors ça a fait du
buzz sur internetin ah ben oui tous les
sites mais tiens ces stratégies on a
parlé oui ça je sais puisque j'ai
rencontré ces gens voilà le site fédéral
aussi oui hein voilà donc ça quand même
fait du c'est voilà c'est quand même un
résultat çaappelle une perf oui c'est
une perf voilà c'est une belle perf
voilà alors qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
tu conseillerit justement au joueurs COM
qui qui rencontent des joueurs beaucoup
plus forts que des grands maîtres ou des
maîtres je crois que c'est justement le
moment de croire vraiment ces idées
parce que quand on est pas on connait
pas la théorie comme c'est mon cas
malheureusement on entre dans des
sentiers que que les joueurs fort
connaissent dans la théorie or l'idée
c'est plutôt peut-être de créer euh sans
prendre trop de risque évidemment mais
de créer quelque chose qui tienne debout
pour jouer le jeu créer et voir ce que
ça donne et c'est ce que j'ai fait hein
dans cette partie finalement je m'en
sors plutôt bien ouais bah oui oui très
bien un bon point donc voilà il faut pas
avoir peur vraiment de ces idées il faut
aller au culot voilà et ça a dit ton
équipe aussi a marqué un point important
pas vraiment parce qu'on avait pas le
niveau pour cette compétition le but
était justement de faire quelque part ça
pas suffi quand même pour l'équipe non
non malheureusement non non les autres
filles ont pas ont pas fait aussi bien
non mais ça leur a fait très plaisir que
je puisse gagner cette partie c'était
comme une victoire pour nous ce jourl
donc d'accord alors on va passer
peut-être si on peut revenir sur le
plateau
euh au niveau caméra voilà juste parce
qu'on va passer maintenant à la partie
du jour alors est-ce que tu suis ce
match euh topalof Kamski petit peu bien
sûr oui voilà alors tu tu as suivi un
peu ce championnat du monde entre anande
et kramnick tu as vu donc la la belle
victoire de euh d'Anand oui et alors le
le vainqueur donc Anand doit jouer
contre le vainqueur de ce match Topalov
Kamski al est-ce que tu connais un peu
ces joueurs est-ce que tu suis les
parties des top joueurs mais pas tous
non et puis j'ai pas vraiment de temps
malheureusement parce que je travaille
beaucoup aussi mais mais ça m'intéresse
parfois bien sûr de regarder ces parties
parce qu'elles sont vives et et de très
bon niveau bien sûr donc on apprend des
choses hein alors on va parler aussi
d'une autre facette de ton de ta
personnalité euh puisque en fait tu
es dans l'équipe tu vas donc être au
comité directeur en fait de la
Fédération puisil y a une seule liste
donc les élections sont déjà disons
faites he bon il faut il y a quand même
un vote mais bon les élections sont
faites alors tu seras donc dans ce
nouveau comité directeur tu tu as été
appelé par Jean-Claude moins et alors
est-ce que tu sais à peu près de ce que
ce dont tu vas t'occuper est-ce que tu
peux nous en parler et ben je crois que
j'aurais pour tâche d'essayer
d'interpréter certains textes qui
ressemblent à du droit puisque c'est mon
métier actuellement voilà donc tu fais
du droit ça c'est ça c'est Al c'est tu
es conseiller juridique c'est ça ou non
je suis une juriste en herbe en fait en
herbe pourquo com ça en her parce que ça
fait pas très longtemps que je fais ça
d'accord ça me plaît beaucoup mais en
tout cas je je débute encore et donc je
sais lire le droit ça peut être utile
pour la Fédération française des échecs
et puis j'ai une petite expérience dans
le droit de propriété intellectuel et on
s'intéressait avec Jean-Claude moins au
droits d'auteur sur les parties d'échec
oui ben ça ça fait des années que ce
sujet bien sûr bien sûr soumis au Cénat
et tout ouais ouis on va essayer de
regarder ça de plus près voir ce qu'on
peut en tirer et voilà pour l'stant on n
pas réussi à au niveau international en
tout cas ils ont pas réussi ils ont ça
fait à en faire quelque chose c'est vrai
que c'est un truc pas évident il pour
les jours d'échec ça pourrait être très
intéressant une man peut-être de revenu
pour certains
alors oui alors après le problème des
droits évidemment il faut que les gens
achètent quelque chose alors est-ce que
ça serait sur les livres fonction voà
mais sû enfin donc voilà donc des sujets
qui peuvent être effectivement
intéressants à creuser et puis il y a
d'autres problèmes de droit qui peuvent
survenir aussi donc sur le droit euh
donc voilà donc dans ce comité directeur
féndéral il il y a de nouvelles têtes
aussi hein que oui il y a plein de
nouvell têtes ce qui est très bien c'est
que cette équipe est assez jeune et
dynamique et puis elle ressemble assez à
Jean-Claude moin qui est lui-même un un
sacré un sacré monsieur donc je pense
qu'on va pouvoir faire de belles choses
durant ces 4 ans dans son équipe ouais
ouais ouais j qu'à la prochaine c'est
c'est chaque année olympique he c'est ça
qui qui aura les élections voà c'est ça
voilà donc ça ça va être intéressant
alors on va venir maintenant sur ce
match Topalov Kamski donc on est à la
partie numéro 4 de ce match Kamski àz
blanc face donc à Topalov donc le match
se joue en Bulgarie chez Topalov c'est
en huit parties euh et on va voir donc
cette partie qui débute par le coup E4
voilà donc on va voir la suite E5 ici
cavalier F3 donc le cavalier ici sort on
l'a répété plein de fois donc il attaque
le pion E5 les Noirs défendent avec
Caval C6 fou B5 donc là c'est une partie
espagnole en tout cas qui débute comme
tel on attaque ici le défenseur du pion
du pion E5 h les noirs attaquent le fou
qui recule cavalier F6 petit rock on
déroule un peu les coups c'est la
théorie on va pas passer là-dessus si
vous voulez approfondir la théorie de la
partie espagnole je vous invite à vous
reporter aux leçons diagonale TV sur la
partie espagnole pour vous expliquer les
idées voilà D6 C3 donc là l'idée des
blancs c'est d'envisager le coup D4 tôt
ou tard alors va pas faire trop tôt
parce que les Noirs pourraient clouer le
cavalier F3 qui défend la case D4 mais
on prépare ce coup ce coup D4 on peut
jouer D3 d'avant avant de jouer D4 donc
c'est un coup classique dans l'espagnol
petit RCK pour les Noirs donc on joue H3
voilà pour éviter ce fameux coup de fou
dont on vient de parler fou B7 et là D4
c'est l'URE là les blancs voilà prennent
le centre ici enfin en tout cas mettre
une petite pression au
centre sortent leur pièces donc tour 8
alors oup tour 8 est connu pour proposer
implicitement la nulle en fait tu
connais le oui j'ai déjà joué ça
l'espagnol quand j'étais un peu oui et
effectivement ça revient souvent ce
coutau8 évidemment parce que les blancs
peuvent jouer le
coup cavalier cavalier G5 cavalier G5
regardez le fou B3 attaque F7 et le
cavalier attaque donc les Noirs ont pour
seul coup intéressant de revenir en F8
et dans ce cas-là les blancs pourrai
revenir en F3 et les Noirs sil rejouent
T8 on rejoue les mêmees choses on peut
arriver à une nulle facile h alors
c'était un ça a été un des débats de
d'une partie carpov Kasparov ah oui euh
et Kasparov avait une petite moue un peu
amusée parce que kpov proposait cette
variante ouais alors qu'il était mené au
score donc ce qui était pas bon pour lui
et KF a refusé quand même de répéter les
coups alors que c'était bien pour lui de
le faire donc c'était un peu curieux
cette cette histoire là enfin bon alors
cavalier BD2 pas soumettre quoi voilà
fou F8 alors maintenant c'est fini hein
parce que si on joue cavalier G5 tout
simplement on joue tour e 7 et il y a
plus de problème on a développé B quand
même cavaler G5 tour au 7 quand même
voilà D5
attaque le cavalier C6 alors on bloque
le centre avec ça ça c'est ça c'est un
alors c'est toujours ce qu'on dit c'est
une décision
responsable c'est sage de bloquer le
centre ouais c'est assez sage après ça
dépend de du style de partie qu'on
souhaite jouer hein voilà alors on peut
aussi laisser tenter de laisser la
pression mais il faut faire attention
parce que les Noirs aussi ont une
peuvent à tout moment prendre en D4
pardon ici menacer de prendre ici en D4
et il y a la tour il a le cavalier il
peut y avoir le fou B7 aussi qui attaque
4 m pression voilà donc il faut faire
attention donc D5 on a plus ce genre de
problème et les Noirs voilà choisissent
alors ça c'est un développement
intéressant dans l'espagnol comme ça on
revient en D8 on va passer en D7 et
venir soit en C5 soit pourquoi pas en
B6 c'est développement possible on est
tranquille alors que c'est une position
de type fermé alors vous noterez
d'ailleurs dans cette ouverture que si à
ce niveau-là il y a aucune une pièce
d'échanger hein pas de pion pas de pièce
et on est quand même au 14e coup c'est
très rare hein c'est vrai je crois c'est
une rare ouverture comme ça qui propose
aucun échange pendant très
longtemps7 C G3
G6 fou C2 qui est classique aussi dans
l'espagnol alors non seulement évidment
je protège ici je protège 4 ici mais je
ça peut aussi se jouer contre la la
poussée F5 qui peut être envisagé
pourquoi pas par les Noirs plus tard
donc le fou une fois qu' en une fois que
le pion est en D5 il est en quelque
sorte bloqué oui donc c'est sans doute
la meilleure diagonale ici pour VO c'est
sans doute la meilleure ici ou c'est
peut-être le plus souple hein pour bien
sûr H6 cavalier F3 alors il y a souvent
des manœuvres dansesagnol où le cavalier
F3 aussi bon il peut faire du travail
ici alors il y a un petit travail qui a
été fait parce que forcer les Noirs
jouent H6 c'est quand même un petit
affaiblissement parce que ce pion H6
maintenant est tapé par le fou C1 alors
il est protégé vous me direz bien sûr
mais ça peut être une cible ça reste une
pression dessus peut être une petite
pression et alors l'idée de
développement pour les blancs c'est
aussi de passer par H2 et venir en G4 et
échanger par exemple le cavalier F6 et
rajouter une pression aussi pourquoi pas
sur H6 et si les Noirs prennent le pion
en G4 après peut être un bélier pour
casser en G5 exactement voilà ce genre
d'idée qui peuvent survenir donc
cavalier B6 le cavalier essaie de de
prendre de l'air de l'autre côté al
regardez il a une case potentielle
pourquoi pas en C4 même s'il tape sur
rien voilà et là voilà H4 alors ça c'est
une autre idée de l'espagnol aussi voilà
on peut jouer avec ce pion h et essayer
de casser là aussi le le le il y a une
petite attaque potentielle du côté ri il
faut faire
attention D7 alors cavalier H2 voilà
c'est l'heure donc cette manœuvre dont
on parlait alors maintenant qu'on a joué
évidemment H4 on peut plus jouer
facilement cavalier G4 il y a le
cavalier F6 qui protège et la dame d7in
mais on prépare aussi le chemin pour la
dame voilà donc on protège aussi la cage
H5 on peut menacer H5 évidemment ça
serait pas bon pour les les noir de
prendre puisque la case F5 ici serait
faible et un très beau cavalier ici en
F5 hein donc peut pas faire ce genre de
de manœuvre alors c'est une partie de
manœuvre pour l'instant toujours aucun
échange hein donc regardez ce qui suit
donc H5 regardez on affaiblit c'est
genre de coup classique on affaiblit on
essaie d'affaiblir le rock on va
échanger un pion ici pourquoi pas et on
on enlève un pion ici du sur la colonne
F on l'éloigne du centre voilà donc on
affaiblit aussi un petit peu le le roin
t
F8 alors cavalier F1 ça c'est encore un
coup euh
euh des manœuvres de de cavalier de la
de l'espagnol aussi alors il va ce
cavalier on sait pas trop pour l'instant
mais il veut peut-être remplacer son
collègue si si si ce collègue part aussi
remplacer en G3 éventuellement venir en
E3 aussi ça c'est des possibilités donc
c'est si c'est l'URE pour les Noirs ça
c'est une poussé thématique pour essayer
de se libérer regardez la pression qu'il
y a pion C6 cal B6 cavalier F6 et le fou
B7 derrière et le fou B7 donc ça les
blancs ben ils ont aucune possibilité de
tenir des sont obligés de prendre en
fait exactement ça force les Chang VO ça
force les Chang et après dame prend C6
regardez les Noirs maintenant font
pression sur le pion 43 pour l'instant
il il est bien protégé ce P Paris qu'il
y a le fou B3 le CAV G3 et la tour
contre TR ça tient voilà alors on peut
noter par contre là il y a il y a un
changement Aurélie dans la structure de
pion est-ce que tu tu peux nous
peut-être nous en parler un peu où tu et
ben il y a il y a des minorités qui sont
créées donc en fait il va pouvoir se se
passer quelques leviers notamment on le
voit du côté de l'il dame pour les
blancs oui on va peut-être pouvoir donc
ici il y a trois pions contre deux c'est
ça que ve tu nous signifier voilà voilà
ir ça permet ça de de créer un pion
passé voilà et il se passe évidemment la
même chose pour les noirs de l'autre
côté voilà alors il y a aussi cette case
dessin qui est alors qui à la fois elle
est pas tout à fait faible parce qu'elle
est bien protégée par B6 par le cavalier
B6 le cavalier F6 la dame et le fou ici
très bien protégé les noirs peuvent
potentiellement pousser le pion D6 en D5
pour se libérer oui pour ouvrir
davantage le jeu par exemple ouais mais
les blancs peuvent enfin devraiit avoir
aussi pour intérêt eux de par contre
d'empêcher les noirs de faire cette
poussée d'où le coup cavalier E3 et là
on voit l'idée de cavalier H2 G1 IL3 en
fait c'était pour viser la case
prophylactique voilàou alors à noter que
si les Noirs font quand même dins qui a
l'air possible puisqueil y a
suffisamment de défenseur en fait en
prenant en D5 certes les noirs peuvent
reprendre ici mais regardez le fou C2
maintenant tape sur G6 et c'est G6 qui
tombe voilà donc on peut pas faire ça en
fait voilà on a l'air de pouvoir mais on
peut pas on peut pas tout de suite donc
cavalier3 empêche dessin en plus
commence à mettre une petite pression
sur desessin les blancs veulent veulent
essayer d'empêcher cette pousser D6 D5
et c'est aidé aussi par ce pion H5 qui
fait pression sur G6 donc d'où le coup
là ro H7 on veut on menace maintenant de
jouer éventuellement D5
voilà dame
F3 donc ça c'est alors la dame continue
à avoir un œil ici sur D5 ici en en
transparence entre guillemets alors
maintenant faut se poser toujours la
question est-ce que D5 est possible coup
de ça serait ça serait envisageable
puisque maintenant que le roi est en H7
on protège ça tente de faire des
sacrifices ça commence à être un peu
tentant tout ça ouais ça ça commence à
être tentant mais alors voilà là les les
blancs auraient pu tenter des choses
comme des cavaliers G5 des ch comme ça
des cavaliers 5 pas tout de suite mais
en tout cas ce sont des idées à à garder
de côté je pense des idé à garder de
côté exactement qu'est-ce qui se passe
sur pionprend par exemple on pourrait
simplement reprendre du cavalier et le
potentiel de libération de prise ici
fait queil y a un fou qui peut faire un
échec à la découverte très dangereux la
tour est attaquée en plus voilà donc ça
peut être très dangereux peut y avoir
des sacrifices donc attention donc le
coup suivant des Noirs s'explique fou
C8 je contrôle voilà cette fameuse case
F5 voilà donc
topalof c'est un très bon attaquant mais
c'est pas un défenseur non plus né la
dernière pluie évidemment il fait
attentionble donc il anticipe en fait un
sacrifice ça c'est fort c'est les grands
joueurs ça c'est les grands joueurs il
voit la possibilité de sacrifice il
l'anticipe
exactement tour D1 fou E6 donc très
important ce coup al très intéressant
Topal à la fois garde un œil sur F5 on a
vu c'est une casse clé il peut y avoir
des sacrifices pour les blancs et en
plus maintenant en E6 il a aussi un œil
sur D5 donc il fait il fait coup double
en fait on voit bien que les Blancs
quand même maintiennent les noirs sous
pression et que ce pion D6 est sous la
pression des blancs les Blancs ont quand
même gagné un petit peu ce combat
d'ouverture du fait de cette
l'initiative voilà petite initiative
petite initiative rien de rien de
gagnant pour l'instant mais forte
pression le pion H5 qui fait pression le
pion D6 qui a du mal à bouger à cause du
Fou C2 qui qui tape quand même sur G6
avec le roit derrière c'est difficile
pour les noirs de de trouver de l'air
ouais et la
cou intéressant de la part des blancs
maintenant c'est le coup B3 alors ça
c'est un coup
surprenant mais tout à fait
intéressant déjà on enlève ici des
possibilités pour les noirs de de de
venir sur sur la case C4 il est pas si
étonnant parce que pourquoi pas un fou à
3 pourrait-il venir voilà
voilà l'autre idée bien sûr
effectivement bien vu Aurélie
effectivement c'est devenir sur A3 et ça
tape regardez sur D6 avit la tour 7
derrière la tour effite derrière ça fait
beaucoup de matériel sans compter que la
tour D1 tape dessus donc on tape sur la
faiblesse des6 voilà mais ce coup se
fait au prix regardez du pion C3 c'est
que les blancs font un
sacrifice alors c'est un pseudo
sacrifice puisque évidemment après dame
prend C3 les blancs pourrai reprendre
sans doute ah non on peut pas tout de
suite parce qu'il y a la tour à un qui
est en prise prendre tout de suite en D6
donc les blancs voilà lâche un pion il
lâche un pion donc fout des de c'est
calculé ils ont pas peur d'avoir la
chpion parce qu'ils ont aussi la colonne
C qui s'ouvre pour eux ils vont pouvoir
activer une tour compensation évidemment
d'activer toutes les pièces de l'Ame
voilà et puis ils disent que tôt ou tard
ils vont le prendre ce pion en fait donc
avec le fou qui va sans doute s'activer
soit en 5 pour attaquer le cavalier B6
soit aussi en B4 et on voit que ce
cavalier a du mal parce qu'il est dominé
à la fois en D5 il peut pas venir à
cause du pion oui il a pas de case
intéressante voilà ni en C4 ni en A4 ou
ou dame C7 x 5 donc la clouage en plus
du cavalier donc ça peut attention ça
peut être très dangereux peut y avoir un
gain aussi rapide de pièces donc d' B8
on enlève ce cl tout de suite et la tour
des de tranquille pour Kamski regardez
l'idée il veut doublerin ou paf paf et
boum on va si on prend B6 regarde il y a
le cavalier qui tombe il y a des pièces
en prise parce queon pourra prendre en
G6 et sur une prise là regardez le fou
risque d'être aussi en pris le mieux
c'est quand même d'essayer de protéger
ce pion6 ou le coup voilà voilà on
essaie de bétonner voilà il bétonne mais
ça fait peine quand même de voir ça ça
fait peine c'est sûr en même temps ce
qu' av B faisait rien du tout VI donc il
est pas pire il est pas pire mais il est
pas beau non plus parce il est très
passif il est pas beauou il est pas beau
donc tour à D1 et là attention la
pression sur D6 augmente alors
évidemment tant que le cavalier C8
protège c'est pas une vraie menace on va
pas donner une tour contre un cavalier
ça c'est sûr c'est sûr et là les noir
jouent B4 alors ça c'est un
affaiblissement par contre alors là
effectivement al B4 affaibli quand même
peut-être avec l'idée d'enfermer ce fou
qui est venu jusqu' alors voilà la
menace aussi des Noirs effectivement
c'est de jouer dame B5 et le fou bah pas
de case et oui pas de cas ou il va le
fou en C7 il est pris de la tour E7 en
D8 par la tour F8 en B4 il y aura
toujours la dame donc menace dame B5
gagne le fou donc piège piège
affaiblissement mais piège quand même
voilà donc ça force Kamski à jouer le
coup suivant mais utile et mais
suffisant dame de voilà je contrôle la
ce B5 et en plus j'attaque à 6 donc
c'est quand même un peu affaiblissant
tout ça si on peut défendre en attaquant
à la fois c'est toujours mieux c'est sûr
voilà alors alors dame 6 c'est pas tout
à fait une vraie menace puisqueil y
aurait tour à 7 attaque la dame et il y
a le fou derrière ouais donc toujours un
problème avec ce fou ouais al roi H8 de
la part de Topalov alors Topalov veut
s'enlever tout problème de on voit bien
que ce vis-àis l'ennuie l'ennuie il veut
jouer des5 il veut se libérer topalof et
donc il veut éviter ce genre de de
désagrément h et là fou des TR alors ça
c'est pas mal alors double intérêt à ce
coup enf
ici de la part de Kamski puisque sur fou
D3 non seulement je tape à 6 et là j'ai
plus peur tour à 7 puisque le Fou est
protégé par la dame mais je libère la
colonne C ouis parce qu'on voit bien
maintenant que le travail est final tant
que le cavalier reste ici il y a rien à
faire mais si j'entre les deux tours sur
la colonne C je peux amener le fou en C7
et je peux à la fois attaquer la dame et
rajouter une pression sur D6 grâce au
fou ouis donc là et je pénître sur sur
la 7e je prends la colonne quoi voilà ou
la position de ce cavalier devient
profitable là pour les blancs si on peut
prendre cette colonne C oui bien sûr
donc tout cavalier A7 alors là il essaie
d'activerin péniblement j'ai envie de
dire ouais c'est le mot he ouais ouais
péniblement parce que bon cavalier a 7
il veut peut-être venir là évidemment si
ce cavalier arrivé mais il peut pas de
toute façon a fou prendre B4 c'est va
pas trop ou ça va toujours pas euh si si
ce cavalier venait évidemment le rêve ça
serait cavalier B5 que les Blancs
fassent rien et cavalier C3 mais bon
c'est c'est c'est c'est même pas
possible mais on peut rriver mais on
peut venir aussi en B5 et envisager
cavalier D4 cavalier C3 ou cavalier D4
parce que là on a aussi en D4 une une un
pion qui protège D4 donc on a deux
belles case ici pour les Noirs donc d'où
l'idée don venir là et ici on forcerait
ce fou à s'échanger et c'est pas plus
mal ouais parce que ces deux fous font
mal au noir pour l'instant ils sont très
actifs comparaisant regardez le fou G7
il est totalement emmuré complèement il
est derrière les c'est un gros pion
comme on dit souvent exactement le fou
comme ça qui pion qui sert à rien voilà
il est bouchonné il peut rien faire et
oui donc tour C1 regardez donc et là bon
ça y est c'est l'idée caler B5 alors si
les Noirs les Blancs faisaient le coup
faut prendre B4 simplement cavalier D4
attaque la dame et la dame B8 prend le
fou donc c'est une faute ça marcherait
pas découverte et donc la menace c'est
cal D4 c'est aussi cavaler C3 qui bloque
toute alors toutes les dam des blancs
tout en attaquant la dame gagnant un
temps donc les Blancs ont pas le choix
il faut prendre en B5 voilà prise en B5
a prend B5 mais par contre le problème
pour les noirs qui était quand même
enuré c'est fou prend B4 et et voilà on
voit là que les Blancs un ont récupéré
leur pion de ils ont toujours cette
majorité que tu nous signalais tout à
l'heure ici qui va devenir de plus en
plus profitable je crois bien sûr et
maintenant comment protéger le pion D6
hein ouais sans compter que la colonne C
aussi est en prise et la dame continue à
faire pression sur le P desess là on
peut dire que l'avantage des blancs il
est clair là oui ça devient un peu
significatif très bien d tout est bien
placé là tout est bien placé en plus ce
fou est super parce qu'il est en plus
derrière le POM B5 voilà donc on peut
même pas l'attaquer il est inattaquable
en plus regardez il a il a il a non
seulement le pion des6 mais il il a une
brochette de pièces ouais c'est ça fait
un peu peur oui exactement ouais donc
tour
D7 regardez tour C6 donc c'est logique
de la part de Kamski donc on rajoute une
pression supplémentaire sur D6 qui est
protégé que deux fois hein h trois
attaques ici tour fd8 donc les noirs
n'ont pas d'autre choix que de rajouter
alors c'est pas plus mal parce que la
tour F toute façon était pas avait pas
de jeu hein oui autant qu'elle vienne
protéger
même si c'est passif et regardez le coup
suivant comme c'est ça Martelle pouf
dame D1 regardez ça rajoute ici une
pressionz comme c'est simple he le jeu
d'échec pratiqué par Kamsk oui quand on
regarde ça comme ça évidemment si un
échange général se fait là à l'avantage
des blanc il est clair il estion et
surtout un pion passé éloigné potentiel
avec ses deux pions contre un ici donc
les Noirs protègent passivement en
jouant le coup fou F8 et là comsk
regardez il a fait dame 2 dame D1 et
regardez maintenant hop dame C2 et il
montre dit non seulement j'ai pression
sur cette colonne mais maintenant en
plus je prends ici la la la colonne C
complètement les les les noirs peuvent
pas contester voilà cette colonne c'est
la propriété des blancs là ouais c'est
la propri exactement la propriété des
blancs c'est c'est c'est bien vu ça
c'est exactement c'est le terme ou ou
c'est juriste ah c'est juriste d'acc ah
oui oui c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai donc la ro H7 de toopalor ça
c'est un coup euh bah c'est un coup
passif presque un coup d'attente j'ai
envie de dire hein oui pour voir j'ai
pas de coup alors j'attends de voir ce
que tu vas faire donc fou A5 de la part
de Kamski attention la tour D8 va devoir
bouger ou alors elle peut pas venir en
C8 puisque il y a tout simplement tour
pr avec la dame derrière donc il faut
venir sur la seule autre case tour 8 on
voit bien que les noirs sont ficelés
donc on voit comment Kamski maintenant
va va transformer tout ça donc h pr G6
échec on reprend du pion F déjà le roi
noir est affaibli regardez on voit bien
qu'il y a de l'air autour du roi noir
regardez le roi blanc au contraire qui
est bien protégé toutes les pièces sont
là il y a aucune pièce noire menaçante
là il y a de l'air on voit bien qu'une
pièce blanche sur la 7è petit échec
pénible dangereux et là regardez sous C7
ça fait très mal la dame B8 attaqué va
falloir bouger et le pion D6 qui tombe
et voilà ça c'est l'heure le c'est mur
comme on dit souvent aussi donc c'est
mur pour prendre fou prend ici fou F7
encore
de de la part de de
topalof et là simplement fou B4 alors
fou B4
l'idée euh surprenant de ce coup c'est
qu'en fait la tour C6 moi j'étais
surpris au début par ce coup mais la
tour C6 attaque aussi le cavalier là
voilà donc euh on se demande pourquoi
pas faire fou prend euh fou prend fou
euh fou prend fou F8 mais tout
simplement parce que les Noirs feraient
fou prend ici d de ouis dame prend forcé
et la tour C6 est perdu alors qu'en
jouant le
coup fou B4 le fou protège en D deux
donc en cas de tour prend tour on
reprendrait du fou mais évidemment les
noirs peuvent prendre le fou B4 mais la
combinaison qui suit c'est simple c'est
les blancs maintenant qui prennent et
après dam prend regardez regardez
regardez comme c'est joli la suite tour
prend cavalier ici donc on récupère la
pièce ici donc on a enlevé le fou parce
qu'on avait pas le choix fallait sortir
en fait on était sous pression on a
éliminé le cavalierin regardez faisons
un bilan au niveau des pions il y a un
pion de plus le roi noir est en l'air il
y a une paire de fou CT du côté noir
mais il y a deux cavaliers en face et
deux cavaliers pour l'attaque c'est très
fort c'est très fort ou donc il faut
faire très attention tour 6 et regardez
la tour regardez hop cavalier
fait téléphoner il est magnifique ce
coup alors évidemment sur tour prend
tour il y a cavalier prend tour la
fameuse fourchette Roy fourchette royale
donc ça on a toujours envie de la placer
celle-là ouiqu voilà la belle fourchette
royale j'attaque le roi et la dame donc
ici al fou F8 de la part des noirs et
regardez comme c'est joli PAF tour F3
alors la tour était là regardez elle a
pris ici elle se retrouve en F3 et où
elle va revenir cette tour regardez
après roi G7 hop tour C3 et voilà voilà
ce qu'a fait cette tour regardez un très
beau
carré joli parcours joli parcours au
passage elle a pris une pièce et elle
revient ces tris avec Dame et tour et la
menace tour c7in avec un gain un gain
rapide parce que si la dame bouge on
aura la 7e rangée et c'est souvent assez
massacrantin on connais ça he donc c'est
ce qui va se passer d'ailleurs tour A6
tour alors tour A6 tour C7 la dame est
attaquée h dame D6 les Noirs ne peuvent
pas prendre ne pourront pas prendre le
cavalier puisque la tour C7 clou se fou
sur le roi
ce cavalier est énorme aussi ce cavalier
au centre ici donc l'avantage blan
l'avantage écrasant mais il reste encore
à le transformer c'est pas simple c'est
toujours c'est c'est souvent le plus
difficile transformer les positions
gagnantes pas toutobtenir fa la gagner
il faut la gagner al dame 2 regardez
c'est intéressant attaque le pion B5 il
faut faire attention à ça aussi mais il
a pas le choixp joue8 il veut déclouer
son son fou D5 et d prend D5 quand
même alors l'idée évidemment c'est que
si les Noirs
prennent le le cavalier en fait les
Blancs ont pas de de souci ils peuvent
encore reprendre du pion puisque la tour
A6 continue à être attaqué ils ont pas
peur de perdre la tour la tour C7 oui
voilà donc faut faut quand même calculer
ça parce qu'oui ça reviendrait un
échange quo ça reviendrait un échange
tour prend à2 de la part de topalo et
voilà donc les noirs sont sont très mal
évidment il y a trois pions contre trois
mais d'abord un ces pions ici sont en de
de os contre un seul du côté blanc donc
affaibli he donc c'est affaibli le plus
faible il y a un pion passé ici énorme
et un très très beau cavalier central
hein donc il faut faire attention à ça
donc dame B7 pression sur le fou sur le
fou F7 pression aussi sur la 7e du dev
désagréable assez rapidement je crois
ouais tout à fait c'est très difficile
déjà pour pour topalof de tenir ça alors
évidemment il va pas réussir à le tenir
on va voir tour 1 échec ro H 2 donc pour
l'instant ça les les blancs les noirs
sont obligés maintenant de d'essayer de
desserer les taux donc il prennent le
cavalier d mais al regardez maintenant
on prend du pion on a libéré un pion et
regarderz ce qui se passe après dame F6
euh
ouais après dame F6 vous allez voir
c'est que le cavalier G3 ici va avoir
plus tard alors pas tout de suite parce
que si on joue cavalier4 on a dam H4 mat
he il y a mat attention menace de mat
ici il faut faire attention mais ce
cavaler une très belle case ici avec un
échec aussi potentiel là on va voir que
c'est très important la prise en dessin
non seulement a donné un pion passé au
blanc qui est proche de de en plus de
l'arrivée mais une très belle case de 4
al on va voir que joue les blancs pour
parer cette menace de math parce que il
y a ma regardez parce que la tour ici
empêche le r noir de bouger hein h dame
C8 très jolie on joue en C8 et regardez
hop on peut revenir en H3 d's c'est ce
qui se passe dame H4 dame H3 échange de
la part des Noirs qui vont essayer de
sauver cette partie dans la finale il
faut que les Noirs arrivent à stopper
ces deux pions passés très fort ça
semble compromis hein al c'est difficile
parce qu'évidemment il y a il y a il y a
le problème aussi que ce ce roi noir est
sur la 7e donc totalement inactif oui
contrairement roi blanc qui va pouvoir
peut-être rentrer en jeu très vite et le
cavalier en venant4 va menacer échec au
roi et avec des menac RSE peut-être des
réseaux de mat et aider avec les deux
pions passés ça paraît très difficile à
tenir on va voir que c'est même pas
possible tour des regardez la manœuvre
cavalier4 évidemment on n pas peur de
tout reprendre cavalier puisquil
cavalier F6 éche auin et fourchette la
fourchette c'est menace et contre menace
alors ça c'est c'est le haut niveau
évidemment des petits pièges de C de
lesquel faut pas tomber hein exactement
FO 3 donc tour a 7 attaque le fou est-ce
qu'il a une bonne case ce fou fou B4
tour B7 de la part des blancs le fou
revient en A3 la tour ici protège le
pion B3 c'est pour ça sans doute qu'il a
fait la manœuvre et maintenant tout
simplement F3 de la part des blancs on
met les pions regardez sur blanc de la
case
opposée sur les cases opposées sur la la
couleur du Fou donc les Blancs ont aucun
souci de protection de de leur pion
voilà sont inat les Noirs ESS d'activer
pénniblement le roi mais bon évidemment
c'est c'est pas avec la tour en 7è c'est
extrêmement difficile roche au moins de
la venue du pion alors par contre là les
noir menac t prend parce que du
coup tour B5 H5 de la part des Noirs roi
G3 on continue on voit la suite alors
tour B8 donc c'est une finale un peu
technique on peut pas commenter tous les
coups on voit la suite regardez donc les
blancs contrairement au noir qu'on un
roi coincé ont la possibilité d'activer
leur roi et de l'amener le plus possible
vers le centre avant d'engager des
manœuvres voilà les blancs même lâchent
le pion G2 regardez ici mais en échange
attaque ici le fou D6 attaque le fou7 on
va sa que ce pion va aller très vite et
après fou D8 tout simplement cavalier C5
déjà regardez donc la menace cavalier
échec et sur roi E8 tout simplement tour
à8 gagne une pièce hein voilà tout
simplement la pièce est gagné et sur roi
E8 tout simplement tour H7 et abandon
d'utopalof les menaces sont beaucoup
trop fortes la menace c'est simplement
D7 échec et sur roi F8 cavalier E6 échc
et c'est finiou il n pas pu beaucoup
respirer il a pas pu respirer donc c'est
vraiment une partie de d'étouffement
cellel ben oui celle-là c'est du
ficelage tu tu en joues toi des
Espagnols aussi avec les blancs ou les
Noirs non plus plus du tout
plus du tout mais tu en as joué bien sûr
énormément parce que on apprend ça quand
on apprend les échecs et que c'est le B
àas parce que ça apprend à développer
ses pièces et on y voit plein de petits
pièges C alors pourquoi plus du tout tu
joues plus tu joues pas au qu avec les
Blancs c'est ça ah tu as arrêté pourquoi
c'est trop il y a des varantes qui
t'embêtent ou c'est surtout qu'il faut
connaître beaucoup de théories sur 4 et
que je la connais pas assez pour pouvoir
le faire et sur des cas tu penses moins
moins je suis plus à l'aise avec des qu
mais il y a quand même y a a des trucs
aussi
chosoup mais bon je me sens plus à
l'aise avec des qucord est-ce que tu
préfères les parties lentes ou les
parties rapides
euh je préfère maintenant les parties
lentes parce que je pratique beaucoup
moins mais fut un temps c'était plutôt
l'inverse parce que tout est possible en
partie rapide pour pe qu'on ait des
réflexes bien sûr oui oui donc il y a
des retournements rour ai ou et des
bonnes idées on fait des parties
sympathiques mais maintenant je suis
plus facile facilement adaptable a des
parti longue parce que parce que quand
on joue moins on a besoin de réfléchir
davantage tout simplement donc je suis
plus à l'aise en partie maintenant
d'accord B alors merci Aurélie pour
cette première émission on va te
retrouver dans une autre émission
toujours pour ce match on va revenir sur
ce match top Kamski dans une autre
émission diagonal TV donc à suivre
toujours sur diagonal TV merci Aurélie
et puis à bientôt à bientôt au revoir
merci